so setup tours are among the most
intriguing and interesting tech related
videos on YouTube sometimes are called
studio tours or tour of a geek setup or
room or workspace or workstation there's
even a subreddit that calls them battle
stations whatever you want to call it it
has a whole lot of popularity on YouTube
last week there was a call for mini set
up tours and dozens of you submitted
videos of your own setups to be
showcased here so welcome to the setup
tour project 2012
we'll start with people who use their
laptop and nothing else as our main
machine hey guys what's up Josiah tech
here and this is my desk now as you can
see it's pretty small
but I like it all my gadgets are right
next to me and close and easily
accessible within my reach and that's
just a benefit I like from my desk
I'd like to share with you some things
about my setup this is my sony vaio
laptop and it is resting on a M design
rate instead I'm using a Apple wired
keyboard we can even Mary keep it
connected to it what's up with your body
styles here and this is a mini tour of
my setup it's pretty simple
as you can see laptop over there on top
of the box and it's pretty special about
my setup is that I actually have another
desk right behind me for studies and all
of that what's going on guys my name is
Tomas and during this video in response
to mkbhd s request for rooms setups I
hope you enjoy I done everything through
text because I tried to keep it down to
its time constraints thanks for watching
and peace
this is my super quick setup tour of my
workspace over to the left I've got my
laptop I've got a clock which turns into
a energy meter
I've got my tablet which is used for for
things like homework while I enter into
Evernote I've got my time tables quite a
lot of my books I've got this little
paper waiter says practice makes perfect
what is up guys this is my setup right
here phone tablet iPod laptop next onto
the people who have a lot of pixels
whether that's two displays or three or
more as you can see there's an iMac here
it's 27 inch quad core i7 with eight
gigs of ram the mid 2010 model connected
to that is my secondary display which is
the frigate so me lobe XL 3 2 to 0t it's
a really good gaming monitor as well as
a secondary display currently I use a
dual monitor setup this is my 13-inch
MacBook Pro values for school and these
are my Android powered devices Nexus 7 P
1000 and the white version of the Galaxy
Nexus I use PC d50 sin Heiser's for
headsets and a black widow for a
keyboard and a Razer Mamba for mice
what's up guys just on with JDK we here
today I've got a quick death setup to
earth first off its my macbook pro 13
inch early 2011 a 24 inch Acer s2 4 3hl
LED monitor a 21 and a half inch asus
monitor an Apple MacBook Air 11 inch
late 2010 an iPhone 4 a blue yeti stereo
microphone a Playstation 3 and also an
Xbox 360 slim below you can see is my HP
printer an Asus wireless access point
and also a link sees gigabit ethernet
switch what's up guys this is my little
workstation the thing that stands out
the most would probably be my
custom-built PC with my dual monitors
I'm not going to go into the specs
because obviously don't have time
another thing would probably my MacBook
Pro which I can hook up to both of my
monitors hi guys stay down here doing a
little office tour walk
the doors of my office and you come into
the right and we've got a printer and
some headphones and a guitar and a
guitar amp and a custom desktop my
father built for me on the floor is a
Mac Pro that I use as a backup machine
in the center is an iMac to the right of
that is a MacBook Pro and the left of
the iMac is another monitor that's
hooked up to the iMac a couple of magic
Mouse's with Magic Trackpad and that's
it thanks guys so this is my submission
hope I make it one thing I really like
about my setup is when I'm editing you
could see I have my TV mounted on the
wall so I could watch TV while I'm
editing in stuff my setup is really nice
I have an iMac MacBook Pro and a monitor
as you can see there's the microphone
I'm using right now the blue snowball
this is technology attics test setup
well it's hard to fit everything within
20 seconds everything is powered by
custom-built PC this includes the 323
inch monitors which are all running
screen savers from really sleek calm and
on the back they have Ikea LED diode
which allows me to change the color
there's an iPad 2 and a Dell XPS M 1330
and you can't forget the audio some of
these guys coming up have some really
interesting audio solutions hey guys my
name is Andrew and this is my desk so I
have a 15 inch retina MacBook Pro iPad 2
and this headphone stands I made myself
it's just stained wood and painted PVC
pipe with a hole drilled into the woods
the pipe can go in and you can just hang
your headphones on there just like that
it's really nice looks great it's easy
to make by yourself
thanks welcome mkbhd fans here's my desk
the reason I love my desk is because of
how simple it is I barely have anything
on it so it's very easy to work on it
without feeling cluttered one of the
unique things about my desk is my
headphone holder may have two binder
clips one with the two-inch long handle
on just the small body it's a very easy
hack to hold my really junky headphones
anyway I love my desk and I hope you do
too
hey marques here's my setup tool video
so here's my Mario oxygen 49 MIDI
controller my macbook air 13-inch
Traktor Kontrol s2 my 27 inch iMac with
a black widow razor keyboard my audio
interfaces are Native Instruments
Komplete audio 6 is my e th and 15th row
yet I'm a ps3 that's about it
just make you up little work
my desk setup I have for my dorm that I
moved into about two weeks ago I have my
two monitors separated there by my right
speaker so my speakers will be
equidistant from both of my ears and to
save space on my desk up top I have my
mic in camera and down below I have my
sub as well as my tower and DAC hey
friends this is a mini tour of my music
production setup alright so first I've
got to bed sheets on the wall to reduce
audio reflections I've got my monitors
on Stan's behind the desk to save space
and improve sound my computer screen is
on a shelf to save even more disk space
I have extra disk space to the left and
right of me for my mixing console and an
extra keyboard and then my master
keyboard my computer keyboard and pad
controller right in front of me the rest
of these submissions are notable setups
that you can probably take something
from and using your own hey everybody
what's up it's Nick here and welcome to
the setup project so here is my setup
now I like to keep my desk kind of clean
and free of clutter so the only things I
have on it are my computer my headphones
and my microphone and then behind me I
have my bed with probably the ugliest
comforter you've ever seen and this is
where I just like to throw papers
whenever I'm working on like school
projects and stuff and then I like to
keep my laptop back here whenever I need
that and what setup would be complete
without having some kickass decorations
so I have my deaf Punk and deadmau5
posters so thank you for watching and
good bye
what's going on everyone it's your
average consumer and although this is a
bit of a smaller desk well I think is
special about it is that everything is
within reach for me I feel it really
gives a boost in productivity I can have
my work tools and my games all in one
area I hope you guys enjoyed this quick
tour of my workspace this is my set up
tour definitely what makes it specials
that I have basically a device from
every platform and OS so from left to
right we have a MacBook Pro with Retina
display third generation iPad Motorola
Xoom Windows Phone fourth generation
iPod Touch 22 inch IPS monitor Galaxy
Nexus
HP Envy Nexus 7 and for what work it
gets to be too much
there's the ps3 and 360 hey guys what
you're probably noticing right now I
said I don't have any sort of computer
or laptop that is because my iPad and
Bluetooth keyboard is kind of like my
computer and it pretty much handles all
the things I want to do on it pretty
well for example video editing on
pinnacle studio and photo editing on
Photoshop top so that's my desk thanks
guys
well guys this is my setup but I really
want to show you guys this great
highlight here I got a bunch of devices
playing this video I want to check it
out yeah it's pretty cool so oh I guess
I'll have a link in the description to
it yeah this is my video response to
márquez's set up to her project 2012 I
kind of got this idea from my boy JJ and
root got the transformer prime HP
TouchPad 23 inch monitor for editing
videos dope premiere a soos g7 for xx
laptop and several devices playing one
video at the same time alright what's up
guys is mkbhd and this is the last part
of the set up tor project 2012 and which
i'll give you a tour of my current setup
so i'm recording with the Canon t2i here
so the focusing is going to be manual so
some stuff might be out of focus
temporarily but I'll give you a good
look at just about everything that I use
here daily and like I said my desk
doesn't really stay the same for too
long but my setup is pretty consistent
usually I'm one thing you notice there's
a lot of stuff is really need that's
just because I tend to be a neat person
but I'm going to start all the way here
on the left because a lot of setup tours
do start here on the left and I'm not
going to give a mini-review per se of
everything in this setup but I will
definitely give you guys names so if you
want to look up things that are in the
setup or that you see just type the name
that I say into the YouTube search box
and you'll be able to find this stuff
and see if I've already done a video
about it so right off the bat all the
way on the left here is a disc this is
not something to find a video on but
this is the design for the school that I
play for right now that I'm
on their Ultimate Frisbee team so that's
the disc and right here all the way on
the left are these two storage bins and
this is these is the place that I keep
things that I don't necessarily need you
know up here or on the desk all the time
so in here you know it's printer paper
for my printer right here I have the you
know extra keyboard storage every geek
has a cable collection I have cables
right in that side part there you know
extra things that I don't necessarily
need all the time and you can also put
stuff on top of that and on the left
here that's also my internet suite so
I'm moving along this is kind of like
the main center piece this is the desk
it's a Vika Alex and I did build this
myself you know how to draw the holes
for cable management which is below the
desk which is why I don't really see a
whole lot of cables especially when
you're sitting down and you got these
legs that attach to it here and the
drawer system all go on the left and I
guess I'll start up here with the router
and this is my internet basically my
internet hub which is nice that it's
right next to where I sit when I'm at my
desk so if anything goes wrong I can
just look at the lights
but this is the router this is the asus
and 66u it's the Cubs nicknamed the dark
knight router and it's it was rated I
got it because it was rated basically
the best router out there so when I was
looking up a router to get for the
apartment I decided on that one and
there's my modem and my ISP gets me
about 60 down 20 up so that's what I'm
getting this on this left surface here
is my tablet say hi this is the Asus
Transformer Pad Infinity the TFC 700
1920 by 1200 display have done a review
on that it is awesome and I use this
basically for consuming media so I watch
a lot of videos on it YouTube videos
when I'm in other rooms in the apartment
stuff like that and a lot of reading
emails because the Gmail client is sweet
so that is the tablet here and I guess
I'll go down because down here are these
drawers and these our school drawers so
I have some organizers in here and I
keep with a lot of stuff in here neat
but I have pens I have microfiber I have
cable to connect the cameras and flash
drives some pencils now
just getting out on these pencils tape
measures and paperclips basically the
top two drawers here are going to be
organized stuff and then bow that I have
notebooks and paper and my textbooks are
behind me in the bookshelf so yeah and I
guess we'll start moving further to the
right here and by the way this guy is
hook it up via ethernet to my desktop
but we'll get to that in a second so
this is the Ultrabook that I happen to
use this is the asus zenbook prime ux31a
also and a full aluminum body so the
construction is really solid but this is
my favorite I take notes on this machine
when I bring it to class this is the
only thing I've taken notes on so far is
just that nice it's really lightweight
performs well better than I really need
it to has a really nice keyboard so and
the trackpad is big I like it this is my
favorite so you can check out my review
on that but uh when this laptop isn't
here this is where I put my notebooks to
do homework so that's the section the
homework section I just have notes data
right up here is the blue spark
microphone this is what I've been using
for more than like the past year but
it's a microphone that I used to record
my videos with and when I want to bring
it out and do a Google+ hangout or a
live show or something like that I just
pull it out it's long enough cable I can
put it anywhere on my desk but put it
right here on top of this lamp and
that's the neat thing this is a lamp
it's an LED light provides sort of this
ambient backlighting so it's kind of
shining up on the wall it gives a little
halo effect but it also spreads light
around the room so there is also two
buttons on here to raise or lower the
levels but I do like this lamp a lot so
I want to favorite pieces of I guess
furniture maybe ha ha ha then there's
the studio monitors a lot of people like
their sound we went over those sound
setups a little bit earlier in this
video but these are these are Aiki audio
m5o 5v2 studio monitors they are amazing
sounding I'm almost hesitant to try
anything else because I'm afraid I won't
like the way they sound compared to
these these just sounds so good right
here we have a
five inch woofer and a one-inch tweeter
excellent sound for the price amazing
sound for the this size the compact size
of these cabinets and they're sitting on
these foam isolation pads from Editors
keys I have not reviewed those but they
are really helpful useful because they
reduce any sort of vibration on the desk
in fact there's zero vibration of
anything it's just pure sound so that's
that's a pretty neat feature that's why
I have those isolation pads and they
Cana you might notice your when you're
sitting in the middle of a both point
towards your ears I used to have them
facing straight out but I find that a
it's really important to have them
facing you for the best quality sound so
they're kind of inverted towards me a
little bit and that's the way they've
set up and I guess we're getting to the
Beast here now this is the the single
monitor setup that I'm currently using
now I've mentioned this before but my
setup rarely stays the same I'm
considering a second monitor actually
for my setup but probably a second
30-inch monitor but this here is a dell
ultrasharp of 3000 7fp say 2560 by 1600
monitor and with a logitech c910 webcam
up top this is easily my favorite
monitor I've ever used I love the 1600
vertical pixels and it's connected to
the boss down here and that is the Mac
Pro now I guess I'll do this first this
is the desktop which you guys are
probably guessed about by now I've moved
past the Mac Mini I'm aware that there's
a new Mac Pro coming out soon but this
will hold me over this is the 2012 3.33
gigahertz six core Mac Pro and basically
the only things I bought from Apple were
the Mac itself and the upgraded 5870
graphics card everything else I bought
an SSD a 512 gigas SD now for myself and
also 16 gigs of ram I did not buy those
things from Apple I bought them from
third parties so that's kind of running
the show right now and that's a blue
lounge cable box which keeps the cables
tidy so I don't have to look at some
crazy cable mess there's a woods in
there
everything like that so then there's the
way you control your computer and
usually my phone is either on my desk or
in my pocket when I sit down I just kind
of put it on my desk
and this is that's the Samsung Galaxy s3
and it's running
Sanna jin mod 10 on it it's getting a
full full day of battery really I
haven't had any battery issues as long
as I've had this ROM so really
impressive rum and then I'm using the
Apple keyboard and trackpad and the
cyborg rat 9 Mouse now a lot of people
would say this is a little bit of a
weird setup but I really only have the
trackpad there for Mission Control so I
have spaces I have three different
spaces open pretty much always for the
same purposes and that's what I use the
trackpad for I like a chiclet style
keyboard matches the monitor you can see
the aluminum going on I like it anyway I
can't really recommend the cyborg rat 9
for everyone it is a great mouse for me
and I had to get I look like the
wireless version because it's so far
from the desktop but I gotta say the
battery life this is not a joke and this
is not a defect it lasts one day on
battery okay so all the batteries
there's there's one battery in the mouse
and there's one battery up here this is
the charger it's green for go like it's
it's on and you can see when I move it
the thing blinks but basically the
battery dives just about at the end of
every day so at the beginning of a new
day you take the new battery out put it
in take the old battery out put it in
charge and you asked about one day on
battery with this guy but anyway I'm
gonna go ahead and show you that's the
controller setup it's also a little bit
of a mouse pad here there's the other
right-hand studio monitor from Ikea do
and right here is the two laptop
chargers for different laptops I use one
of them is sittin right there and the
other one is in my closet it's a fatty
but that's my uh the school provided
laptop which isn't the best which is why
I got that
and then there is breakfast of champions
just give that a second there yeah there
it is breakfast of champions here's the
Nexus 7 one of my favorite tablets out
there but I don't use it all that often
because
is I use the pad infinity a lot and this
is just kind of for having a nexus I
mean I like the fact that this infinity
runs stock Android but this guy right
here is a pretty solid I think it's off
right now actually yeah it's running
stock Android and I just use it for the
app so a lot of the apps experience is
really nice but seven inch form factor
is cool but that's basically everything
under here you can see Andy just kind of
chillin with the cyborg a charger thing
and if you want to look at it to my doc
there you go
that's what's open right now anyway and
there it is that's my wallpaper I have a
wallpapers album in Google+ so if you
want to check that out my Google+ length
is always in the description of my
videos so I wallpaper album up there and
that's basically it so if you have any
questions obviously feel free to post
them down below we can discuss this we
can discuss why I haven't gotten a
freaking second monitor for this yet
which second monitor I should get should
I get another one of these probably will
end up getting out of one of these to
have them identical but yeah that's
basically it for my current set up so if
you like this sort of a setup tour
project idea definitely be sure to leave
a thumbs up on this video and if this is
a good enough project for you guys I
will probably be doing this sort of
project I get every year though it takes
a long time to compile and download all
these videos to give you guys all your
shout outs but there you go this has
been the mkbhd setup tour project 2012
thank you for watching and I'll talk to
you guys in
peace
you